Starship Troopers seems to have a happy
ending with their Heroes defeating their
enemies and going off to successful
military careers at the start Rico is a
conflicted character who is unsure of
his place in the military Machinery he
joins the mobile infantry but not out of
any sense of patriotic duty while it's
true that his military service will
guarantee him citizenship his desire to
continue a romantic relationship with
Carmen is what draws him into the war he
shows compassion and conscientiousness
during his training as well as deep
regret when he directly contributes to
the death of a fellow Soldier during an
exercise gone wrong it's not until the
invasion of clendathu after his parents
are killed in the Buenos Aires attack
that Rico drastically changes into a
killing machine Starship Troopers ends
with an in-universe propaganda video
encouraging new recruits to join the
military so they can be heroes like Rico
for a man as initially open-minded as
Rico this is an unhappy ending he is now
truly just a cog in the war machine